ici à mort ans et en eure-et-loir et
mini ferron m'attend afin de me faire
découvrir l'esprit guinguette alors
préparez vous pour un voyage dans le
temps nous allons danser le madison le
charleston et le rockabilly avec des pin
up des années 30 car c'est ça
[Musique]
ambiance guinguette centre val de loire
est bien petite démonstration de danses
d'époque
[Musique]
invités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour emilie s'allier kamini pour
faire une guinguette ça veut dire que en
choix il faut l'esprit guinguette il
vous vient d'où avoue cet aspect que
j'allais voir les guinguettes à tour et
puis je me suis dit que amour on sait où
on était il y en avait pas et qu'il
fallait créer ce genre de choses et
c'était parfait on avait un cadre
idyllique pour faire tout ça et qui
vient ici alors de lag et servait de on
va dire de de 25 à 90 ans en fonction de
la programmation on m'a vraiment de tout
et en fait c'est ce qui m'intéressait au
début du projet c'était vraiment de
créer un lieu intergénérationnel
le but c'est que tout le monde se parle
tout le monde communique on puisse
échanger qu'on est un lieu de partage et
quels types d'événements vous organisés
ici bon il ya des concerts n'y a pas que
ça alors on est tout un tas d'événements
on a des concours de pétanque on a des
vide greniers de la danse des karaokés
[Musique]
complet et à d'autres qui viennent de
sortir à karaoké déjà ça je vais
participer quand ma gueule ok ce cas-là
magal johnny c'est pourtant décrite par
johnny chan est
donc déjà karaoké 1 ça je viens mais
dans concours de pétanque je me suis
entraîné tout l'été sur la côte d'azur
regardez la gestuelle sont au val de
loire je reviens ici à l'heure de la
digue et faire un concours de pétanque
l'année prochaine alors vous avez parlé
de pin up oui est ce que c'est possible
de les rencontrer et bat avec grand
plaisir je vous les présente allez c'est
parti
le pin up avec la chef et bien su entier
miss beach miss betim mesdames les pi 2
po bonjour vous habiller en pin up du
lundi au dimanche exact h 24 h mais
comparé au moment du coucher j'ai besoin
mais non nous qu'est la nuit j'ai aussi
mes dessous des 50 authentique ah ok
d'accord à quoi ça ressemble et nous
soient nés cinq ans parce que là on est
dans des jeux
wii alors montrez nous alors on va voir
tac tac tac donc le bas le
porte-jarretelles longueur et après on a
la guerre mondiale alors vous votre
surnom c'est miss betty est ce que tout
le monde un surnom ici moi j'ai un nom
de scène les filles sont ces partis tour
de table mismari
sweetnam une orbite à baby doll kelly
chery ap oceana muscat mini la plus sexy
du tout ouais on va parler musique et
des musiciens venez me ce métier on va
les changer
d'homme rock'n roll
attention
[Musique]
si on fait
centre val de loire
[Musique]
c'est kameni
[Applaudissements]